ich fand sie haben das wort liebe frau
welti meine damen und herren in
absprache mit der bundespressekonferenz
werden wir in der nächsten zeit wieder
wöchentlich an dieser stelle zur krone
lageberichten für diese möglichkeit
möchte ich mich ausdrücklich bedanken
der regelmäßige krone -bericht wieder
wöchentlich ist aus unserer sicht in
dieser lage auch erforderlich das
erlaubt uns nicht nur ihre fragen zu
beantworten sondern schafft auch das
öffentliche bewusstsein dafür wdr wie
ernst die situation ist und die
situation ist ernst und ich empfehle uns
allen sie auch ernst zu nehmen die
infektionszahlen steigen sehr stark wir
liegen inzwischen bei einer sieben tage
incidents von über 260 und die
ansteckungsrate der er wert ist schon
viel zu lange seit ende september
deutlich über 1 das heißt wenn nichts
passiert werden sich die instanzen
weiter alle zwei wochen verdoppeln ich
habe im juli mal gesagt wir müssen im
oktober mit insolvenzen von 800 und mehr
rechnen wenn auch etwas später ist dass
das was wir jetzt auch in einigen
regionen sehen
was so hohe infektionszahlen bei
gleichzeitig noch zu geringer impfquote
bedeuten sehen wir bereits jetzt auf den
intensivstationen in einigen regionen in
deutschland insbesondere in sachsen
thüringen und bayern es gibt dort
kliniken die sind heute schon über dem
limit in diesen regionen
besteht aktuell das risiko wenn sie ein
notfall sind schlaganfall herzinfarkt
dass dort nicht immer sofort vor ort die
kapazitäten zur verfügung stehen die sie
sonst gewohnt werden das ist bitter und
das ist die situation die wir immer
vermeiden wollten und weiter vermeiden
wollen wir müssen jetzt alles tun alles
notwendige tun um diese dynamik zu
brechen sonst wird es für das ganze land
ein bitterer dezember
die gesundheitsminister von bund und
länder haben vor einer woche in lindau
oder zu drei wichtige punkte beschlossen
zum einen auffrischimpfungen für alle
nach sechs monaten nach der zweiten
impfung schärfere auflagen und
kontrollen beim zugang zur veranstaltung
und verpflichtende test konzepte für
pflegeheime beim impfen sehen wir und
das ist gut wieder mehr tempo wir haben
auch deutlich anziehende bestellungen
seitens der länder und der arztpraxen
wir haben allein in dieser woche wieder
über 4,3 millionen impfdosen an die
impfzentren an die länder und an den
großhandel für die arztpraxen
ausgeliefert das ist eine vervierfachung
im vergleich zu dem was wir in den
letzten wochen gesehen haben
mittlerweile haben über zehn prozent der
über 60 jährigen in deutschland eine auf
geschimpfe erhalten hier in berlin
jüngst sogar schon über 20 prozent alle
länder haben sich mittlerweile
entschieden die älteren schriftlich über
die auffrischimpfung zu informieren und
sie ihnen zu empfehlen die länder und
die behörden vor ort fahren auch die
öffentlichen angebote wieder hoch wir
haben stand heute wieder über 170
impfzentren und stellen im land und über
600 mobile im teams der öffentlichen des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienstes die
impfungen anbieten und ich werde per
verordnung sicherstellen dass die
impfzentren der länder bis mindestens
ende april weiterhin zur hälfte vom bund
finanziert werden
wir bieten zudem den ärztinnen und
ärzten in den arztpraxen mehr anreize um
ihren praxisalltag auf das impfen
auszurichten wir werden die vergütung
für die impfung erhöhen von 20 auf 28
euro um 40 prozent und es wird ein
wochenend zuschlag geben von nochmal
acht euro für jede impfung so dass dann
eine impfung am wochenende 80 prozent
besser vergütet wird als heute
dieser verordnung werde ich am montag
unterzeichnen das gilt dann ab dienstag
impfen macht den entscheidenden
unterschied das gilt auch weiterhin aber
das impfen braucht eben auch zeit es ist
seine volle wirkung jeweils entfalten
kann deswegen müssen wir in dieser lage
rasch wieder deutlich mehr testen dazu
ist ja vereinbart führen wir die
kostenlosen bürger tests wieder ein und
sichern damit auch den kurzfristigen
wiederaufbau
der flächendeckenden test infrastruktur
finanziell ab die test verordnung die
das möglich macht die die bürger tests
wieder einführt unterzeichne ich heute
sie gilt ab morgen und ich gehe davon
aus dass dann ab anfang der woche nach
und nach auch wieder das angebot vor ort
ausgebaut wird und mehr verfügbar ist
ich appelliere an alle bürgerinnen und
bürger die angebotenen im pfund
testmöglichkeiten auch zu nutzen
allerdings und das sage ich mit der
erfahrung aus drei corona wählen das ist
alles richtig und wichtig aber
das reicht so alles nicht jedenfalls
nicht mehr es braucht dringend
zusätzlich eine testpflicht für personal
und
besucher ins pflegeheim das ist im
übrigen auch wichtiger als eine
verpflichtende impfung in diesem bereich
weil auch geimpfte und genesene besucher
und beschäftigte in den
pflegeeinrichtungen aus unserer sicht
regelmäßig getestet werden müssen
idealerweise täglich um den eintrag in
die pflegeeinrichtung zu vermeiden es
braucht 3g am arbeitsplatz ist es gut
dass gewerkschaften und arbeitgeber das
nun mittragen und eine gesetzliche
regelung kommen soll
und dann werden wir uns auch über die
auflagen für veranstaltungen unterhalten
müssen 3g war eine gute idee aber es
blieb zu oft theorie 3g war zu oft 0 g
weil es nicht wirklich kontrolliert
worden ist und damit auch keinen
wirklichen effekt erzielen konnte das
können wir uns nicht mehr erlauben nicht
in dieser lage
mehr noch 3g alleine wird nicht mehr
reichen wenn wir die aktuelle dynamik
der pandemie wirklich brechen wollen
müssen wir entschlossener handeln
und dazu gehört eben auch das testen bei
dieser hohen inzidenz wo auch die
geimpften und genesenen teil der
infektions entwicklung in deutschland
sind das geht dann eben auch durch
testen bei geimpften und genesenen
deshalb wäre es aus meiner sicht aus
unserer sicht konsequent wenn wir
öffentliche veranstaltungen erstens nur
für geimpfte und genesene ermöglichen
und 2 1 0 dann wenn diese zusätzlich
einen aktuellen test verweisen zweig
plus das ist wieder ein schwerer schritt
ist mir sehr bewusst aber ich bin davon
überzeugt das ist ein schritt den wir
gehen müssen und wir können ihnen nur
gemeinsam gehen die instrumente für das
was ansteht haben wir wir müssen sie
aber eben auch anwenden und
kontrollieren und es braucht ein
gemeinsames signal dass wir uns gegen
diese vierte welle stemmen auch deshalb
brauchen wir die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz das treffen
von bund und ländern aus meiner sicht
hätten wir schon vor drei wochen
gebraucht die vielstimmigkeit der
vorschläge der letzten wochen haben nur
für verwirrung gesorgt und sie haben
dazu geführt dass zu viele die korona
auflagen nicht mehr ernst nehmen so
schwer das ist in dieser zeit des
übergangs zwischen alter und neuer
regierung wir müssen wieder eine
gemeinsame sprache finden und zu einem
gemeinsamen handeln kommen um leid zu
verhindern um eine überlastung unseres
gesundheitswesens zu verhindern und um
die bevölkerung mitzunehmen
auf diesen schweren weg jetzt insa
vierten welle der pandemie die so in
dieser dimension viele zu meinem
eindruck nicht mehr erwartet haben wir
sehen im übrigen das noch hinzufügen
darf hatte gestern einen dänischen
kollegen getroffen ein beim
niederländischen kollegen gerade
austausch gehabt auch viele andere
länder in europa die schon weiter waren
auch bei lockerungen sehen jetzt in
dieser vierten welle das eben weitere
maßnahmen wieder nötig sind und weitere
maßnahmen gemeinsam durch diese vierte
welle das geht nur entschlossen und
gemeinsam
meine damen und herren es ist fünf nach
zwölf
das hier ist die aktuelle karte der
sieben tages inzidenz aus deutschland
sie sehen dass fast alle landkreise
tiefrot sind im süden und im osten sehen
sie auch diese pink
landkreise das sind etliche landkreise
in denen die sieben tage incidents über
500 liegt
und vielen liegt zu über 800 der 904
sogar über 1000 in diesen bundesländern
kommen krankenhäuser und
intensivstationen jetzt schon an ihre
kapazitätsgrenzen und ist nicht absehbar
dass sich die lage dort entspannen wird
andere bundesländer sind im moment noch
nicht an diesem punkt wir müssen aber
davon ausgehen dass sich die situation
überall in deutschland weiter
verschärfen wird und das ohne
zusätzliche maßnahmen auch nicht mehr
aufzuhalten ist die intelligenten
steigen teilweise sprunghaft an vor
allem bei den fünf bis 19 jährigen aber
auch in allen anderen altersgruppen auf
den intensivstationen liegen bereits
mehr als 2800
komapatienten die behandlungskapazitäten
schwinden
derzeit gibt es tatsächlich so wenig
begreifbare betten wie noch nie in
dieser pandemie mehr als die hälfte der
intensivstation melden dem intensiv
register akute personalengpässe so viel
wie zuletzt auf dem bisherigen höhepunkt
im januar diesen jahres die vierte welle
trifft uns jetzt mit voller wucht und je
schneller und die hört sie sich auftun
desto schwieriger wird es sie auch unter
kontrolle zu bringen und desto
verheerender sind natürlich die folgen
ich möchte dass anhand der aktuellen
infektionszahlen der ost mit den
aktuellen hospitalisierung skate und dem
fall verstorbenen anteil einmal
verdeutlichen gestern wurden erstmals
über 50.000 fälle an einem einzigen tag
übermittelt so viele wie noch nie von
diesen 50.000 fällen an einem tag werden
im laufe der zeit etwa 3000 im
krankenhaus behandelt werden
von diesen 50.000 fällen müssen
schätzungsweise
mindestens
350 auf die intensivstation und nach
einiger zeit werden von diesen 50.000
menschen mindestens 200 versterben
natürlich können die zahlen die ich hier
genannt habe auch schwank das hängt von
vielen faktoren ab je mehr ältere
personen betroffen sind desto höher sind
die sterbefall zahlen zum beispiel es
geht mir darum ihnen diese größenordnung
klar zu machen
das ist die bilanz von einem tag mit
50.000 fällen momentan und es ist wie
gesagt absehbar dass die fallzahlen
weiter ansteigen vor uns liegen also
schwere wochen und monate wir müssen
jetzt ansteckungen verhindern
kurzfristig durch die uns allen
bekannten und bewährten infektionsschutz
maßnahmen und mittelfristig durch mehr
impfungen wenn sie noch nicht geimpft
sind lassen sie sich bitte impfen wenn
eine auffrischungsimpfung für sie
empfohlen ist lassen sie sich bitte auf
ihre auffrischungsimpfung holen um die
situation so rasch wie möglich zu
entschärfen müssen alle zusätzlich ihr
verhalten ändern reduzieren sie ihre
kontakte vermeiden sie vor allen
situationen den mehrere menschen in
räumen zusammenkommen bitte halten sich
immer und überall andrea h und l regeln
auch bei 2g und 3g veranstaltungen
tragen sie also auch bei 2g eine maske
wenn sie symptome einer akuten
atemwegsinfektion haben bleiben sie
bitte unbedingt zu hause und lass dich
pcr testen darüber hinaus empfiehlt das
robert koch-institut je nach situation
auch weitere zusätzliche maßnahmen in
unserem kontrollwut dokument stellen wir
schon lange ein stufenplan zur verfügung
wer hilft die lage in den bundesländern
einzuordnen und wir empfehlen für jede
stufe angepasste maßnahmen
und zwar für verschiedene settings eine
bundes einige bundesländer haben bereits
die höchste stufe dieses planes die
stufe 2 erreicht in dieser stufe zwei
reicht zweig alleine nicht mehr aus um
das infektionsgeschehen einzudämmen für
stufe 2 empfiehlt das robert koch
institut deshalb weiter kontakt
reduktionen das waren zb bei
großveranstaltungen
veranstaltungen die personenzahl
reduziert oder ein verbot erwägt das man
aber in erwägung ziehen sollte auch bars
oder clubs zu schließen für stufe 2
empfiehlt das ärgert auch dass sich alle
auch geimpfte und genesene testen bevor
sich auf wat mit risikogruppen treffen
alle diese empfehlungen haben wir seit
september in der aktuellen kontroll
kowitz strategie auf unserer startseite
abrufbar sie müssen jetzt umgesetzt
werden wir befinden uns in einer sehr
ernsten lage wir haben es jetzt in der
hand jede unnötige infektion zu
vermeiden bitte lassen sie uns doch
einfach gemeinsam jetzt handeln jede
person in deutschland ab zwölf jahren
kann sich schützen wir haben sichere und
wirksame impfungen vergessen wir nicht
dass wir auch immer noch eine gruppe von
menschen haben die sich noch nicht
impfen lassen können alle kinder unter
zwölf jahren sind das nämlich aber auch
die müssen wir doch schützen und die
schützen wir mit wenn wir uns impfen
lassen wir könnten das virus übertragen
ohne es zu wissen oder uns mit dem virus
anstecken ohne es zu ahnen
diese kette müssen wir durchbrechen wir
können das tun indem wir unser verhalten
anpassen und verantwortungsbewusst
handeln
vorbeugen ist besser als heilen
dann sage ich danke schön bisherige
liegen schon zahlreiche wortmeldungen
vor deswegen die dringende bitte eine
frage eine nachfrage und wenn sie sich
kurz vorstellen wir starten mit der
kollegin bitte schicken sie
sind dann sorgten das mikro davor gehen
wir müssten ins mikro sprechen wie der
minister hat franck haus hat gestern von
realitätsverweigerung gesprochen weil
die ampel epidemische lage abschafft das
war ja ursprünglich mal ihr vorschlag
wie denken sie darüber
nun wir sind uns völlig einig in der
union um mein eindruck dass auch darüber
hinaus drei fehlen dass es darum geht es
ja
weiterhin maßnahmen und möglichkeiten zu
maßnahmen und das sehr umfassend für die
länder braucht ich habe am 15 oktober in
einem schreiben an die drei ampel
koalitionäre die parteien die dabei sind
eine mehrheit zu bilden eine mehrheit zu
werden einen brief geschrieben in dem
ich drei optionen aufgezeigt habe in
denen sichergestellt werden kann oder
mit denen sichergestellt werden kann
dass die länder die behörden vor ort
weiterhin den maßnahmen katalog die
rechtliche grundlage dafür haben den sie
brauchen die ampel hat sich entschieden
keinen dieser drei wege zu gehen
und insofern verstehe ich unterstreiche
diesem punkt auch wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die länder rechtlich das
haben was sie brauchen um je nach
situation in ihrem land und der
sächsische ministerpräsident hat ja sehr
eindrucksvoll auf die situation etwa in
seinem bundesland noch mal hingewiesen
auch gestern um in der sie auf die
situation in ihrem land zu reagieren ich
kann nur dafür werben dass eben auch
ernst zu nehmen und diese rechtlichen
möglichkeiten nicht einzuschränken das
ist ja im moment der vorschlag sondern
den instrumentenkasten dort offen zu
lassen drei wege dahin habe ich
aufgezeigt
das heißt wenn sie ihren vorschlag aus
dem oktober jetzt so nochmal formulieren
ich sage noch einmal sie können die
epidemische lage verlängern sie können
den 28 da müssen sie nur 56 worte
verändern als grundlage für die länder
geben oder sie können den absatz
728 arm ist technisch zusagen bestehen
lassen so dass die länder je nach ihrer
regionalen lage eine epidemische notlage
erklären können entscheidend ist ich
finde da muss jetzt ein bisschen
aufpassen dass wir nicht irgendwie so
scheinen debatten führen über die frage
wie entscheidend ist doch die frage dass
die länder und die behörden vor ort
den maßnahmenkatalog haben den sie
brauchen und flexibel reagieren zu
können und diese pandemie hat uns eines
gezeigt und zeigt es uns gerade in
dieser vierten welle wieder es lässt
sich selten drei oder sechs monate im
voraus alles schon immer denken und
planen und deswegen ist die debatte die
zu führen ist aus meiner sicht ob es
klug ist einen abschließenden nicht
flexiblen maßnahmenkatalog zu
beschließen wo sozusagen nicht das was
eins zu eins wortwörtlich da steht dann
nicht auch noch irgendwie vor ort
angepasst werden kann an die lage und
das ist die debatte die jetzt parlament
habe stattfindet und ich finde ich
richtig und wichtig
eine frage an herrn wähler ab welcher
größe sollte es keine
großveranstaltungen mehr geben auch zum
beispiel keine vollen fußballstadien
diese debatte hatten wir ja im letzten
jahr die größten die wir da genannt
haben haben sich als
wirksam erwiesen und es gibt eigentlich
keinen grund an diesen größen zu
zweifeln wir wissen sehr gut dass
insbesondere in innenräumen
sogenannte super spreading events
stattfinden und wir wissen auch dass die
delta variante ja noch
ansteckender ist als die vorherigen
varianten insofern sind
großveranstaltungen
generell wirklich kritisch zu sehen und
wenn sie durchgeführt werden dann mit
maximaler sicherheit die uns zur zeit
zur verfügung steht also mit all den
werkzeugen die wir haben am besten wäre
es wenn man bestimmte
großveranstaltungen absagen würde ganz
klar
die intensivstation sind ja einen
bestimmten bereichen jetzt schon voll
aber ich möchte noch mal folgendes sagen
das habe ich auch mir oft gesagt es kann
doch nicht das maß sein ob ein
intensivstation voll ist es kann doch
niemand von uns ernsthaft wollen dass
möglichst viele intensivstationen voll
sind dann wäre ja die logik wir tun noch
10.000 intensivstation bauen was
natürlich nicht geht und dann können wir
noch 10.000 menschen mehr behandeln wir
wollen doch dass die gar nicht erst da
hinkommen also ich meine das muster
unser aller ziel sein die infektionsrate
zu senken und wir können froh sein dass
wir noch so viele intensivbetten haben
faktisch aber wir haben ja deutlich
weniger als letztes jahr um die zeit
wegen des personalmangels und wir haben
eine zweite situation inzwischen weil
der altersdurchschnitt der patienten ja
auch geringer geworden ist liegen viele
intensivpatienten auch länger auf der
intensivstation also die kapazitäten
sind unabhängig davon geringer geworden
also bitte lassen sie uns doch dafür
sorge tragen dass wir gar nicht erst in
die situation kommen in die jetzt leider
schon wieder einige krankenhäuser sind
aber lassen sie uns doch die situation
vorbeugend reduzieren dass wir das nicht
als eine marke nehmen die wir erreichen
wollen das kann doch nicht unser ehrgeiz
sein zumal wenn ich das ergänzen darf
die momentan der lage auch einfach so
wahnsinnig viel konflikt führt ich mein
der geimpfte krebspatient bekommt
möglicherweise eine operation verschoben
weil ein umkämpfter 19 intensiv platz
braucht das alles führt auch zur
gesellschaftlichen spannungen
pflegekräfte bei denen sie spüren die
brennen für ihre aufgabe aber sie sind
eben auch ausgebrannt nach drei wellen
wenn man da 45 stunden im coop 19
intensivbereich am stück in voller
montur das ist ja anders als bei anderen
intensivpatienten das muss man glaube
ich auch immer wieder deutlich machen
der aufwand der betrieben werden muss
ohne große trinkpause ohne die
gelegenheit sich zu erleichtern da steht
dann ist das eine wahnsinns belastung
und deswegen und das haben wir hier
tatsächlich häufig beide miteinander
gesagt kann es nicht der ansatz sein zu
schauen was halten die intensivstation
irgendwie in der maximallast aus das war
nie unser ansatz und sollte es auch
nicht sein und wir sehen im übrigen auch
das andere respiratorische
atemwegserkrankung ihr auch noch da sind
und stärker wieder da sind ein grund
mehr übrigens neben der auffrischimpfung
und decke ohne impfung auch die
grippeimpfung wahrzunehmen
die nächste frage von herrn steigen
ulrich stoll zdf frontal minister die
pflegekräfte haben mir mitgeteilt dass
sie ja schon seit jahren am limit sind
dass wir schon seit jahren ein
pflegekräftemangel haben auch auf der
intensivstation und das nur noch eine
minimale betreuung aber nicht mehr wenn
der rehabilitieren die mobilisierung von
denen sich patienten mögliches hat die
politik haben sie in den letzten jahren
in der intensivpflege etwas versäumt das
haben die pflegekräfte ja nicht nur
ihnen mitgeteilt sondern es ist eine
öffentliche debatte die höhe jetzt keine
neuigkeit das wie eine herausfordernde
schwierige situation in der pflege
insgesamt haben das sage ich seit
dreieinhalb jahren und daran arbeiten
wir seit 3 jahren auch sehr konkret das
haben wir gemacht wir haben der sparen
zu lasten der pflege in den
krankenhäusern beendet indem wir die
pflege rausgenommen haben aus den
fallpauschalen aus der logik auch der
fallpauschalen gesagt haben jede
zusätzliche stelle und übrigens auch
jede tariferhöhung jede tariferhöhung in
der pflege wird zu 100 prozent von den
cup grad personal der zweite schwierige
teil ist diese stellen zu besetzen und
die ausbildung von pflegekräften zumal
von intensiv pflegekräften
intensivpflege braucht fünf jahre das
ist nicht in sechs monaten oder 12 oder
24 getan sondern es braucht eben wegen
der guten ausbildung der wichtigen
ausbildung auch länger also die stellen
sind geschafft die bessere bezahlung ist
durch tarif refinanzierung möglichen
personalschlüssel die werden ja gerade
wieder diskutiert
wenn der erste minister seit über 20
jahren der personal vorgaben eingeführt
hat in den kliniken konkret auf zwei
patienten intensiv muss mindestens eine
pflegekraft kommen wir sind gestartet
bei zweieinhalb zu 1 und jetzt bei 221
und man wird sich auf weitere schritte
gehen müssen um das pflegepersonal auch
auf intensivstationen zu entlasten aber
das kann man eben nur gehen wenn
gleichzeitig das personal sich aufbaut
weil sonst sehr die versorgung nicht
sicherstellen können auch das war ein
ganz ganz wichtiger schritt genau diese
personalbedarfsermittlung gehen wir
jetzt weiter und aus meiner sicht götter
zu ihm auch insgesamt eine diskussion
über
über die bezahlung nach fünf jahren
ausbildung
35 38.000 euro jahresverdienst staub es
gibt bereiche wo sie nach fünf jahren
einer solchen intensiven ausbildung auch
deutlich mehr verdienen auch das ist ja
eine debatte bei der ich jedenfalls was
das thema tarif refinanzierung angeht ja
auch sehr klar sagen die müssen wir
führen insofern ständig züge sind noch
nicht da wo wir hin müssen
und gerade diese pandemie und auch diese
welle zeigt dass nochmals aber wir haben
den weg begonnen
und begonnen vor allem die spirale in
die falsche richtung jetzt in die andere
richtung zu drehen aber wir sind noch
auf dem weg
am ziel
die personal untergrenze scheidung
sollte dafür sorgen dass eben pfleger
nicht überfordert sind die krankenhäuser
ziehen daraus die konsequenz einfach
brechen zu sperren darum haben wir wie
professor wähler sagte ja eben weniger
intensivbetten als früher darum nochmal
die frage ist zu spät um gesteuert
worden ist zu spät der aufbau der
intensivpflege kräfte vorangetrieben und
von der politik
nun ich bin jetzt seit dreieinhalb
jahren minister
ich kann ihnen jedenfalls sagen das von
tag eins an dass unser großes thema war
eines der ersten gesetze das wir gemacht
haben war das pflegepersonal stärkung
gesetz ist richtig erinnere gleich im
jahr 2018 sogar noch in kraft getreten
nach regierungsübernahme wir haben den
fokus in diesem bereich jedenfalls in
den letzten dreieinhalb jahren im
krankenhaus sehr sehr stark gehabt wir
haben übrigens auch so viele
auszubildende in der pflege wie noch nie
zuvor in der geschichte unseres landes
aber wir sind eben und da gibt es nichts
schönzureden wir sind noch nicht da wo
wir hin wollen und wo wir hin müssen der
weg ist aber begonnen aber natürlich ist
durch diese drei wellen der pandemie
auch einfach die belastung poste ja auch
entsteht wenn man jetzt seht wie viel
eigentlich vermeidbar wäre durch mehr
impfungen zum beispiel das alles kommt
er sozusagen zu dem was sowieso schon an
problemen da war noch zusätzlich dazu
noch zum zusätzlich schwer
online die frage von verena kneipps man
vom orf wahrscheinlich eher an herrn
jeder kann sie bestätigen dass
österreich ab sonntag wieder als
hochrisikospiel eingestuft wird und was
bedeutet die damit einhergehenden der
reisewarnung für den winter so etwas
muss ja können wir bestätigen ist
einfach auch notwendig aufgrund der
infektions lage und dynamik und das
heißt eben beim hochrisiko gebiet werde
nicht geimpft oder genesen ist muss bei
rückkehr in quarantäne
dann hätte eine frage an herrn villa
herr villa sie hatten bis anfang
november auf ihrer webseite die aussage
dass geimpfte bei der epidemiologie der
erkrankung keine wesentliche rolle mehr
spielen diese aussage kamen darunter war
auch die aussage dass die viruslast bei
geimpften pikant reduziert wird dies
auch nicht mehr da gibt es da neue
erkenntnisse wenn sie das vielleicht
noch mal erläutern können ja tatsächlich
gibt es neue erkenntnisse wir können ja
die effektivität von impfungen immer nur
dann in quasi in der echtzeit im
nachhinein betrachten denn wenn menschen
geimpft sind und dann infiziert wurden
dann wird sich ja im laufe der wochen
und monate erhält man ja erst die daten
vor allen dingen also wohl aus unserem
land als auch aus anderen ländern und es
gibt ein paar entscheidende unterschiede
am anfang als die impfungen eingeführt
wurden hatten wir hauptsächlich die
alpha variante und andere varianten die
nicht so hoch ansteckend waren wie jetzt
die delta variante das heißt es ist
tatsächlich so dass wenn sie die
effektivität anschauen die wir ja in dem
wochenbericht doch immer ausweisen dass
die impf effektivität schwächer ist als
sie vor einigen monaten waren gelte
variante deutlich ansteckender ist wir
sind inzwischen bei einem wert von etwa
60 prozent das sind die daten die wir
aktuell berechnen können schutz vor
infektionen das heißt also sechs von
zehn geimpften werden geschützt vor der
infektion wir hatten früher höhere daten
und wenn wir uns die ineffektivität
anschauen dann sehen wir auch daniel
leichten ist nach wie vor eine sehr sehr
hohe wirksamkeit aber auch hier sehen
wir den leichten abfall wir sind bei
etwa 90 prozent schutz vor
krankenhaus-aufenthalt und bei etwa 94
prozent schutz vor droht das sind immer
noch wirklich sehr sehr hohe
effektivität aber tatsächlich haben sich
durch die veränderung des virus diese
effektivität ein wenig reduziert
deswegen weil ich das ergänzt
tschuldigung deswegen propagieren wir ja
oder bewerben wir gerade auch so stark
ja die auffrischimpfung weil die
erkenntnis ja ist das haben wir schon im
sommer gewusst und deswegen im sommer
vereinbart pflegebedürftige höchst
betagte frau erkrankte auffrischimpfung
anzubieten erst erkenntnis ist das ist
die personengruppe bei der dieser
zusätzliche schutz vor krankheit einfach
erklären können ich meine sie können die
die in methode die wir ihm für
effektivität berechnen die steht er in
diesen wochen berichteten wir ja jeden
donnerstag berichten also der auf
unserer webseite auch für jeden
einsehbar sind wir berechnen das anhand
der uns gemeldeten zahlen wir bekommen
wir bestimmte zahlen gemeldet von den
gesundheitsämtern und in den geist das
wäre natürlich nach ärztlicher
entscheidung jetzt jemand da ist der vor
fünf monaten und sieben tagen die zweite
impfung hatte dann kann er natürlich die
auffrischung zwei es ist ja nicht so ein
stichtag sozusagen exakt sechs monate
danach ist der impfschutz weg das ist ja
nicht er ist noch da aber sechs monate
für das minus ist halt der anhaltspunkt
wo wir sehen dass insbesondere das
reduzieren der ansteckung
währungen dieser pandemie genau das was
er wieder an mahnt was nicht sein kann
bleiben sie dabei dass sie sich an
wieder als paar angestoßen herr jungen
sie konstruieren der vierbeiner gesagt
wieder ein gegensatz den es nicht gibt
ich habe erstens vielfach auch an dieser
stelle auch ein anderer stelle gesagt
können sie auch google
dass wir eben nicht warten wollen bis
die intensivstation voll sind dass sich
diese kategorie nie verstanden habe die
einige haben nach dem motto geschaut
wieviel weit wir noch gehen können was
die intensivstation noch schaffen weil
das belastung ist für die pflegekräfte
und leid für die patienten und ihre
angehörigen und gleichzeitig gilt das
was sie zitiert haben ist er trotzdem
richtig dass die tages zahlen die
tagesaktuellen zahlen die wir im
register haben aus den intensivstationen
mit sozusagen das meinte ich mit
härteste währung als bild die
belastbarsten zahlen haben über das sind
über das was wir aber
das was wir im land das
infektionsgeschehen und
krankheitsgeschehen verbunden mit 19
sehen dass eine ergänzt er die andere
aussage
und er will ein lern frage warum
empfiehlt das lka weiterhin das
vollständig gegen 19 personen nach
kontakt mit einer nachweisbaren positive
person nicht in quarantäne müssen muss
sich das mittlerweile nicht ändern warum
ist das so
das ist eine sehr gute frage die wir
auch tatsächlich momentan überlegen ob
wir das ändern
das kann ich ihnen momentan noch nicht
beantworten tatsächlich ist es so dass
von den vollständig geimpften ja auch
infektionsgefahren ausgehen insofern ist
es ein sehr relevanter frage wie wir
markus bader aus dem
ard-hauptstadtstudio am minister spanne
in umfragen ist eine mehrheit der
deutschen für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht warum sind sie weiter
dagegen eine allgemeine impfpflicht ja
also wir können ja einfach mal die frage
eine allgemeine impfpflicht
durchspielen was heißt denn dass das
heißt das dass wir von haustür zu
haustür gehen
und uns welche behörde polizei
von jedem bewohner in einem haus dämpfe
nachweise zeigen lassen und wenn die
nicht geimpft sind dann machen wir was
also ich finde es ist immer alles so
leicht gefordert und hat so leicht an in
der umfrage ja klar schneller aber es
heißt im allgemeine impfpflicht also das
ist für bestimmte einrichtung
voraussetzungen gibt zweig geimpft zu
sein und dann können sie es
kontrollieren bei der veranstaltung
übrigens dann auch wirklich
kontrollieren es gibt ein kostenloser
control
kostenlos kann jeder runter lang jeder
kann sogar bei seinem
familienmitglied kontrollieren ob der
impfpass echt ist und ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir diese kontrolle auch
nutzen dann bei 2g und zwar nicht durch
nur drauf gucken sondern durch
einscannen weil das eben mit dem server
dann gecheckt ob das tatsächlich auch
eine richtig erstelltes im zertifikat
ist aber jedenfalls um dahin
zurückzukommen bei veranstaltungen ist
das möglich aber eine allgemeine
impfpflicht wo sie sozusagen jeden
bürger jede bürgerin
verpflichten sich im was machen sie mit
dem der sich weigert zu hören wir dann
leider sahra wagenknecht mit der
landespolizei zu impfstelle oder wie
also ich will dass überspitzt das jetzt
einfach etwas damit einfach mal deutlich
wird was diese forderung wenn man sie
mal zu ende denkt tatsächlich bedeutet
und ich glaube einfach dass das nichts
ist was in dieser sowieso schon
spannungsreichen zeit tatsächlich unsere
gesellschaft die nötigen zusammenhalt
bringt und bin trotzdem ziemlich klar
wie sie wissen für impfen und auch für
unterschiede zwischen geimpft und nicht
geimpft etwa eben bei veranstaltungen
gerade auch bei jüngeren menschen wächst
gerade die angst wieder vor dem virus um
von der ansteckung und das eventuell
weiterzugeben würden sie angesichts
dieser lage gerade dazu raten
silvesterpartys zum beispiel im
freundeskreis zu planen oder davon wie
war abzusehen
also silvester ist ja noch ein stück hin
aber ich kann ihnen nur sagen dass ich
persönlich keine silvester party
besuchen würde und
alle partys die stattfinden insbesondere
in innenräumen sind eben potenziell ort
wo man sich anstecken kann und es muss
wirklich jeder darüber nachdenken ob er
sich diesem risiko aussetzt also west
der glaube wir sind sechs wochen und ich
persönlich werde keine silvesterparty
ich empfehle übrigens nicht einfach bis
zu silvester zu wahren ob man über sein
verhalten nachdenkt oder nicht die
silvesterparty ist er ist synonym wir
haben jetzt wieder eine fahrt haben
eigentlich die ganze zeit seit 18
monaten einfach eine situation wo es um
dieses zusammenspiel geht auch von
eigener verantwortung im alltag und
entschlossenem staatlichen handelns und
übrigens um es noch einmal zu sagen die
allermeisten bürgerinnen und bürger
leben ja auch diese verantwortung passen
auf sich und auf andere auf schützen
sich impfen sich testen sich
und darum geht es jetzt eben auch wieder
sich einfach zu überlegen im alltag
was ist jetzt sozusagen nötig was tut
mir vielleicht auch gut nach 18 monaten
ja aber wie kann ich dann so machen dass
es wenn es denn sein muss
höchstmöglichen infektionsschutz
bedeutet und das heißt eben zum beispiel
auch selbst test sind ja nun auch
wirklich mittlerweile vielfältig
verfügbar ja es gibt jetzt mal ein zwei
tage weil die nachfrage gestiegen ist
vielleicht mal lokalen der knappheit
aber das wird sich sehr sehr schnell
wieder wenn da habe ich gar keine sorge
der welt mal gibt das her für tests dass
man eben wenn man die großeltern besucht
im zweifel einmal den selbsttest macht
das machen viele doch jetzt schon so und
deswegen ist diese frage was passe ich
in meinem eigenen verhalten an in einer
vierten welle mit höchst inzidenz
in diesen 18 monaten nicht nur eine die
sich auf die silvesterparty bezieht
sondern eigentlich auf alles was dazu
ansteht
sie freundet wegen des boosters sie
hatten von die frage von kollegen ob das
nicht vorzuziehen ist uns erreichen hat
sich mal wieder meldungen dass leute die
fünf monate und drei wochen haben zum
beispiel zurückgeschickt werden vom
hausarzt mehrfach die politik erklären
uhr berichtet auch ist könnten sie was
sagen sie dazu zu diesen vorfällen
also mein eindruck ist dass ist ja etwas
was ich so den letzten ein zwei wochen
wir müssen noch mal schauen nicht mal
die zeit vergeht einerseits so stellt
andererseits ist alles auch noch nicht
so lange her ich habe mich gerade erst
letzte woche donnerstag vor gut einer
woche haben wir uns ja geeinigt mit der
ärzteschaft weil einfach in diesen sechs
monaten in sich ja schon die
priorisierung liegt werden wir zuerst
bei den älteren beim medizinischen
personal feuer kranken begonnen zu
impfen wir haben uns vor gut einer woche
auf dieses gemeinsame vorgehen
verständigt und das muss jetzt natürlich
habe dann mit herrn kasten dem
vorsitzenden der kassen bundes
bundes kassenärztlichen vereinigung kv
kassen bundes die bundesvorsitzende der
kassen ärzte jedenfalls darauf auch
verständlichen gemeinsamen schreiben an
die erste schafft zu machen ich glaube
das kommt jetzt einfach so nach und nach
im alltag an auch was diese flexibilität
angeht auch dass man im zweifel jemand
der 64 ist oder 57 und eine
auffrischimpfung einfach auch für die
eigene sicherheit sich wünscht dass da
geimpft wird und mein eindruck ist auch
angesichts der bestellung ich habe mir
gerade gesagt erstmalig seit ziemlich
langem wieder über vier millionen
impfdosen in einer woche ausgeliefert
einfach ins system
dass das jetzt auch einfach passiert das
sehen wir ja auch an den impfzahlen es
geht jetzt eben auch deutlich
mehr auffrischt dienst und ich glaube
auch dass mit der nötigen pakt mit dem
nötigen pragmatismus zunimmt klickt auf
die uhr und mit blick auf meine lange
liste mit wortmeldungen muss ich ihnen
leider sagen dass wir wahrscheinlich
nicht alles durch bekommen aber wir
machen einfach mal tapfer weiter
charlotte kurz pharmazeutische zeitung
stichwort boostern was halten sie davon
die apotheken jetzt mit in die kurve 19
impfkampagne einzubinden um die booster
geschwindigkeit zu erhöhen weil die
hausarztpraxen zum teil termine erst im
januar anbieten
also zuerst einmal
habe ich ja gerade gesagt werden wir die
auch einfach finanziellen anreizes ist
einfach ein aufwand jetzt natürlich im
praxisbetrieb wieder impfsprechstunden
möglicherweise auch am wochenende
anzubieten werden wir jetzt noch mal die
vergütung für das impfen von 20 auf 28
euro erhöhen und am wochenende auf 36
euro das ist glaube ich auch für die
erste schafft noch mal ein deutlicher
anreiz neben dem was sie sowieso was
ärztlichem tunnel heraus ja auch
beitragen wollen in dieser pandemie dass
auch anzubieten und zum zweiten hat die
frage ob apothekerinnen und apotheker
impfen oder nicht so viele heilkundliche
berufsrechtliche haftungsrechtliche
folgefragen dass das jedenfalls nicht
innerhalb von wenigen tagen zu regeln
wäre ich nehme den punkt gerne nochmal
nochmals mit ich weiß aber auch das ist
jetzt nicht die lösung für die nächsten
zwei wochen dafür ist es viel zu komplex
wenn sie ins mikrofon sprechen dann
können wir sie ein bisschen besser
verstehen ich weiß das ist blanker maske
aber es lässt sich nicht ändern also es
wurde ja sehr deutlich gemacht und ihren
kollegen der union dass es das falsche
kommunikatives signal radio chemischen
notlage zu beenden vor kurzem gab es
hier auch eine baby karner sagst auch
mal klassen unter anderem aus der
ärzteschaft wo es auch darum gehen dass
aus der politik das falsche signal
ausgegangen ist wir haben dieses signal
sende würden sie jetzt angesichts der
lage auch im nachhinein sagen
lassen dass gesagt
derjenige der vom freedom day aus meiner
sicht völlig egal aber jedenfalls was
die frage epidemische lage angeht ich
sage noch einmal wir können jetzt also
wenn der deutsche bundestag ist
entscheidet ja nicht der bundesminister
für gesundheit
der deutsche bundestag ganz allein
entscheidet darüber ob eine epidemische
lage die wird übrigens nicht beendet
sondern sie wird wenn da nicht
verlängert schon mal ein unterschied der
deutsche bundestag allein entscheidet
darüber
und das ist völlig okay wenn es daneben
der bundestag so oder so entscheidet ich
habe nur erstens beschrieben was
jedenfalls auch da die signale aus dem
parlament waren dass es keine allmend
arische mehrheit für eine verlängerung
gäbe wenn es die mittlerweile gibt hat
ich sicher nichts gegen eine
verlängerung der epidemischen lage
es entscheidet der bundestag
und zum zweiten habe ich am 15 oktober
gesagt
ob sie verlängert wird oder nicht ist
nicht der entscheidende punkte
entscheidende punkt ist
dass die länder eine grundlage haben für
ihr handeln das ist der entscheidende
punkt wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen
aufpassen dass wir nicht so eine
scheindebatte führen und nicht über das
eigentliche reden es geht darum dass die
länder
einen rahmen haben und die behörden vor
ort auch in den kreisen in den städten
der es ihnen möglich macht maßnahmen zu
ergreifen
dazu gehört im zweifel auch
eben über das hinaus was jetzt im
gesetzentwurf steht
mit blick auf gemeinschaftseinrichtung
möglicherweise tätig zu etwa oder
möglicherweise bei ungeimpften auch
weitere schritte zu gehen im alltag das
ist ja eine frage die regional dann
entschieden werden muss und verantwortet
werden muss sie muss halt nur möglich
sein und das ist eigentlich der
eigentliche punkt der debatte auch der
gestrigen bundestagsdebatte ist es klug
in dieser phase der pandemie die
rechtlichen möglichkeiten der länder
einzuschränken
und ich habe schon am 15 oktober in
einem schreiben darauf hingewiesen dass
ich jetzt nicht für klug halte es
einzuschränken ich habe letzte woche
hier schon gesagt wenn mit meiner
aussage zur epidemischen lage die eine
rechtliche war zum ausnahmezustand
rechtlicher art eine falsche botschaft
verknüpft gewesen sein sollte bei
einigen dann muss ich das einfach
selbstkritisch aussagen dann habe ich
das nicht klar genug formuliert die
pandemie ist nicht vorbei
das ist auch das worauf herr professor
wieder und ich glaube ich seit vielen
wochen darauf hinweisen manchmal denke
ich mir hätten wir vielleicht im
september noch deutlicher darauf
hinweisen müssen
wenn wir haben sich dass wir ich weiß
nur noch wir haben eine pressekonferenz
bei ihnen im mrt gemacht wo wir die
modellierung vorgestellt haben die frau
bundeskanzlerin weiter da schon darauf
hingewiesen alle drei was bei bestimmten
impfquoten sich entwickeln kann das war
im sommer
das ist ja nicht so ich habe 100
wahlkampfreden oder reden quer durch die
republik in jeder rede in jeder
gesagt es wird im herbst winter eines
passiert
entweder man ist geschützt durch eine
impfung oder man wird sich ohne schutz
infizieren
das ist haben wir alles gesagt ich werde
gar nicht nach dem motto zwar gewusst
ich will nur sagen es passiert jetzt
nichts gerade was nicht eben auch schon
vorher also zu sagen und prognosen oder
ein aussagen von uns allen gelesen ist
und die frage ist ja dann haben wir
vereinbart wir ergreifen bestimmte
maßnahmen
wir haben übrigens vorgeschlagen im
august 2 gg instrumentenkasten zu haben
2g mit regeln zu versehen ab welcher
inzidenz hospitalisierung oder
infektionen 2 gilt
und das ist dann nicht in den bund
länder beschluss eingeflossen beschreibt
das jetzt nur
dann gab es den 3g beschloss den ich
richtig finde grundsätzlich für herbst
und winter aber dann muss 3g auch
kontrolliert werden damit es einen
unterschied machen kann so und insofern
finde ich muss jetzt ein bisschen
aufpassen dass wir nicht so eine
scheindebatte führen über
epidemische lage ja nein das ist doch
nicht der punkt um den es gerade geht in
dieser lage des landes und der punkt um
den es geht ist haben länder und
behörden vor ort die möglichkeiten
maßnahmen zu ergreifen die sie brauchen
und ich bin der festen überzeugung ist
braucht mehr als aktuell
möglich gemacht werden soll
apropos instrumentenkasten gernot heller
korrespondentenbüro herholz lockdown zum
instrumentenkasten gehören und
gegebenenfalls wieder angewendet werden
zumindest
als option
regional auch weitergehende maßnahmen
das ist ja das was ich gerade
beschrieben habe
weitergehende maßnahmen angehen zu
können
ist das aus meiner sicht schon wichtig
dass das einfach auch weit nach
verhältnismäßigkeit überprüfung jeder
einzelne anordnung bringt jede anordnung
einer preisvergabe oder einer
landesbehörde muss immer wieder auf ihre
verhältnismäßigkeit im vorhinein jahr
überprüft werden und abgewogen werden
aber aus meiner sicht sollte der
instrumentenkasten sozusagen der
maßnahmenkatalog wie er heute im 28a ist
und das war ja unser vorschlag auch
möglich bleibt
frage wenn jetzt alle die die
tatsächlich schon geimpft sind wenn die
jetzt alle tatsächlich losgehen würden
und sich durch boostern würden also die
dritte impfung oder bei johnson johnson
die zweite film wurde hätten wir da eine
chance die herdenimmunität dann
irgendwann im januar doch noch zu
erreichen stimmt wäre das möglich also
doch eine herdenimmunität denn die die
nicht impfen wollen werden sich auch in
den nächsten vier wochen nicht empfehlen
also wenn wir eine immunität eine rate
von impfungen momentan haben von etwa
zwei drittel der bevölkerung in
deutschland oder bis zu 70 prozent sagen
wir mal diese rate reicht nicht aus wir
haben ja modellierungen im juli diesen
jahres publiziert da haben wir gesagt ab
75 prozent voller im schutz der
bevölkerung hat diesen wirklich einen
effekt auf den verlauf der pandemie aber
trotzdem müssen immer noch zusätzliche
maßnahmen durchgeführt wenn das heißt
also nein boostern alleine reicht nicht
um genügend grund immunität zu erreichen
aber ostern erhöht den immunschutz schon
stark und ostern erhöht auch die die
oder verringert auch die viruslast wenn
die gehen dann noch mal infiziert werden
wir hatten
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere werten
immer kommuniziert dass es irgendwann
eine auffrischungsimpfung geben muss wir
wussten aber nicht wann weil wir
natürlich keine erfahrung hatten jetzt
in sechs monate und zeitraum wo sich
zeigt dass das dass das so ungefähr der
richtige punkt ist variiert
das heißt aber um ihre frage zu
beantworten nein es reicht nicht für
diese grund im monat also jeden
immunität möchte ich auch noch mal kurz
erklären herdenimmunität der begriff den
haben wir eigentlich gestrichen wir
können dieses virus nicht ära die zieren
das wort herdenimmunität beinhaltet
eigentlich dass man das ziel des virus
zu reduzieren das verschwindet es wird
nicht verschwinden wird sein zoonose
erreger ist das wird er in dem ich es
wird also bleiben aber unabhängig davon
heißt das also messerscharf wir müssen
noch mehr menschen zum impfen bekommen
oder diese menschen werden sich halt
selber infizieren und wie viele menschen
sich infizieren und dann eine immunität
erreichen bzw schwer krank werden oder
auch versterben das hängt von dem
verhalten der menschen ab das heißt also
wir werden dann sehen ob wir im nächsten
frühjahr ich weiß nicht wie viel prozent
der menschen dann diese impfung hatten
oder eben
quasi natürlich infiziert wurden mit dem
risiko bis hin zum tod und wenn eine
bestimmte anzahl der menschen dann eine
immunität besitzt dann ist die
grundelemente hoch genug damit die
pandemie beendet ist aber das heißt
nicht dass das virus nicht dass es
verschwindet sondern wenn dann eine ende
haben das heißt dann wird das eine
krankheit sein wie viele andere die nach
wie vor noch auch zu todesfällen führt
aber sie wird eben nicht mehr dazu
führen dass sie in irgendeiner weise
unser system überlastet wenn es wird
eine von vielen krankheiten sein und je
mehr menschen einem mobilität haben
desto geringer wird die krankheitslast
und jeder wirklich vernünftige
verantwortungsvolle mensch möchte lieber
diese immunität bekommen durch eine
impfung stadt durch eine natürliche
infektion ja es ist einfach der bessere
weg die impfstoffe sind sicher und
wirksam das heißt nimmt quote von 90
prozent wären das immunitätsrecht
dass wir sogar 90 prozent von der
gesamtbevölkerung wenn das erreicht ist
dass die immunität dort ist dann haben
wir einen signifikanten einfluss nachdem
modellierungen die wir im juli
publiziert haben allerdings hat sich das
virus auch verändert das hatte eine
etwas höhere ansteckungsrate das heißt
also wir müssen wirklich wirklich
mindestens 90 prozent der menschen im
land müssen eine immunität haben um das
vernünftig kontrollieren zu können
bitte
buchsteiner
ja wir können sie kaum verstehen er will
ein buch steiner von pioneer mit einer
kurzen nachfrage zu den schulen ich habe
in der vergangenen woche diese woche mal
nachgefragt bei der kmk wie viele
schüler infiziert sind die konten
medizin für vergangene woche geben
23.000 was wissen sie über das
infektionsgeschehen an den schulen und
über krankheitsverläufe von sagen wir
unter zwölfjährigen ja wir wissen das
was wir in den meldezahlen sehen ob das
steht in dem wochenbericht drin wir
wissen also über die anzahl der
ausbrüche wissen die durchschnittliche
anzahl der ausbrüche gesehen das was
gemeldet wird also wir haben nach wie
vor natürlich eine sehr geringe quote an
kindern die sehr ernsthaft erkranken
sehr sehr sehr wenige ich bin ich
richtig im kopf sind 30 bislang die
verstorben sind die wir da zu ordnen
können wir wissen natürlich nicht genau
was in den schulen exakt passiert wir
kennen natürlich auch die hygiene
konzepte nicht die in jedem bundesland
und in jeder schule durchgezogen werden
das wissen wir nicht wir wissen dass es
länder gibt die unsere empfehlungen
umsetzen dass sie nämlich sogenannte
lolli pcs machen also regelmäßig test
machen wir empfehlen dass er schon sehr
sehr lange und diese länder dort warten
dann infektionen früher erkannt und dann
werden natürlich auch weniger in
quarantäne gehen und wir wissen auch
dass es länder gibt in denen das nicht
gemacht wird das heißt das variiert sehr
stark wir wissen aber dass wir sehr hohe
zahlen haben bei diesen jungen menschen
also die sehr hohe inzidenz das heißt
also wohl die optischen immer der schule
angesteckt haben dass das können wir
natürlich nicht nachvollziehen wenn man
bestimmte untersuchungen gemacht wo wir
dann exemplarisch einige ausbrüchen
untersucht haben aber das genaue
geschehen können wir nicht exakt
benennen aber klar ist diese kinder
stecken sich natürlich in der schule
auch an und sie können dann natürlich
auch ihre umgebung ansteckt und darum
ist ja unsere empfehlung masken tragen
den schulen steht aber auf unserer
website zu vielen vielen monaten
regelmäßig testen lolli pcs am besten
und wir wünschen eben auch dass alle die
die sich mit diesen kindern umgeben so
die lehrerin
die eltern und die betreuenden dass die
alle sich impfen lassen damit sie eben
die kinder durch diese impfung mit
schützen und da haben wir übrigens ein
riesiger unterschied wir haben
bundesländer wo von den 12 bis 17
jährigen bereits über 60 prozent geimpft
sind wir haben bundesländer in denen es
halb so viele sind und auch natürlich
macht die impfung in diesen
altersgruppen ein unterschied
stand jetzt gehen wir davon aus dass in
den nächsten 46 wochen eine zulassung
für einen stoff für fünf bis elfjährige
erfolgt und auch dort wollen wir dann
natürlich weil dieser impfstoff für uns
verfügbar ist rund um den jahreswechsel
dann impfung beginnen
schnell
noch einen kuss nachfrage gibt es
schwere verläufe bei kindern ohne
vorerkrankung sind oder sind die ganz
ganz selten können sie dazu etwas sagen
es gibt schwere verläufe ja auch bei
kindern ohne vorerkrankung aber sind
trotzdem seltene ereignisse ja aber auch
seltene ereignisse sind aus meiner sicht
den versuch wert sie zu verhindern wer
möchte schon ein kind mit einem
inflammatorischen syndrom im krankenhaus
sehen oder im in der behandlung wenn er
diese infektion hätte vermeiden können
darum nochmal mein appell dass die
infektion schutzmaßnahmen nach bestem
wissen und gewissen stringent
durchgeführt werden die letzte frage
verleitete dankeschön daniel heid von
n-tv ersparen wie immer die ersten
bewohner medikamente empfohlen ich warte
hat sich die bundesregierung schon darum
gekümmert diese medikamente auch
einzukaufen oder bereitstellen also wir
haben jetzt eine zulassung durch die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde ja für
erste antikörper medikamente ins
paradies von regeneron orange haben wir
uns im großen umfang schon im november
letzten jahres vor zwölf monaten
gesichert auch in deutschland verfügbar
kommt im übrigen auch jeden tag seit
wochen und monaten in deutschland zum
einsatz diese monoklonalen antikörper
sind ja so eine art passive
immunisierung sie machen besonders viel
sinn bei risikogruppen etwa bei älteren
bei menschen mit vorerkrankungen sehr
früh nach der infektion endlich sobald
die infektion bekannt ist sollte bei
diesen
personengruppen dann die gabe das ist
eine infusion 3 45 stunden aber die gabe
dieser monopole ein antikörper erfolgen
weil wir wirklich sehen in den daten
dass das einen echten unterschied macht
für den weiteren verlaufenden risiko des
weiteren fall also die gerade
zugelassenen haben wir in ausreichender
menge für deutschland gesichert schon
vor zwölf monaten und vollwertig die
noch sich in der auswertung der daten
befindlichen beiden wenn ich jetzt mal
die beiden von msd und pfizer nehme die
beiden die den vorteil haben dass sie
keine infusion sind sondern pillen und
die sind natürlich leichter zu nehmen
als wenn sie stundenlang eine infusion
geben müssen müssten dann aber genauso
frühzeitig den risikogruppen zur
verfügung gestellt werden mit beiden
unternehmen sind wir auch in gesprächen
um eben entsprechend für deutschland
frühzeitig so früh es jedenfalls geht
dann auch entsprechende verfügbarkeit
sicherzustellen dass b fahren also unser
zulassungsbehörde ist auch in gesprächen
mit den unternehmen um mir einfach die
daten zu besprechen das eine sind ja
immer pressemitteilungen das andere ist
tiefer auch in die daten einzusteigen
und auch diese gespräche finden schon
seit ein zwei wochen ich glaube sogar
darüber hinaus intensiv statt ein
schneller und kurz gesagt ganz kurz in
die wanten die medikamente dann auch
kontraproduktiv für die impfkampagne
seien kontraproduktiv
jetzt hängt es gibt eine pille und muss
jetzt nicht mehr impfungen das sehe ich
dass ich nicht
es mag einzelne geben und wundert sich
ja sowieso über es gibt ja jetzt auch
diejenigen die jetzt die
auffrischimpfung als argument gegen
impfen nutzen also das ist mir köln hat
nie vermeiden in einer freien pluralen
gesellschaft dass auch viel unsinn
auch sozialen medien erzählt wird
wir können immer nur wieder aufklären
und informieren
und die impfung schützt wurde und
wirksame medikamente helfen übrigens
auch den geimpften bei denen es mal etwa
bei frau erkrankten einen durchbruch bis
hin zur erkrankung geben kann ist ja
nicht zu 100 sondern zu über 90 prozent
ausgeschlossen
und dafür sind die medikamente wichtig
aber ich kann jedem nur empfehlen ist
nicht auf die also wer es drauf ankommen
lässt im zweifel medikament zu kriegen
das vielleicht zu 50 oder 70 prozent
aber auch nicht zu 100 prozent einen
unterschied macht kann ich nur empfehlen
den weg zu gehen das ist der sichere und
trotzdem sichern wir uns natürlich die
therapeutika und vielleicht noch
ergänzen die nebenwirkungen dieser
medikamente sind natürlich stärker als
die nebenwirkung von impfungen das
sollte man auch nie im kopf haben wenn
diese debatte kommt ja
gleichzeitig das noch sagen darf als
positiven ausgang sozusagen ist es ja
erst mal ein riesen glück wenn es noch
mal sagen da ist und wir uns dass wir
seit 18 19 und 20 monaten kennen und wir
haben sichere wirksamen stoffe und wir
haben die ersten medikamente bei denen
wir sehen dass sie einen echten
unterschied machen das hat so schnell
jedenfalls
für impfstoffe und medikamente in der
menschheitsgeschichte noch nicht gegeben
und bei allem was wir gerade an leid und
schwierigkeiten sehen finde ich ist das
doch immer wieder auch etwas was zuvor
sich gibt den teils über nicht vergessen
hat sich dank für den besuch an diesem
freitag ich bitte um verständnis bei all
denjenigen
wo die fragen für heute nicht
beantwortet werden konnten wir müssen
einfach auch wenn die technisch ein
bisschen auf die zeit achten und ich
möchte auch noch einmal darum bitten bei
unseren mitgliedern dass sie auf die
mail achten die wir ihnen heute morgen
geschickt haben ab sofort ffp 2 in
diesem raum vielen dank
[Musik]